- Our next speaker is Judith Litchman,
who is Susan Dwight Bliss Professor
and Chair of Chronic Disease Epidemiology
at Yale School of Public Health
and Director of the Humanities Arts
and Public Health Practice at Yale
or HAPPY Initiative.
Dr. Lichtman's research focuses
on examining the epidemiology of stroke
and heart disease using
longitudinal databases
and prospective observational studies.
She has served on several
national committees related
to cardiovascular
and cerebrovascular disorders
and has been a member
of the program committee
for the American Heart
Association conference
on cardiovascular disease,
epidemiology and prevention,
and has served
on numerous national
American Heart Association
and American Stroke
Association writing committees.
She was the recipient
of the C Miller Fisher, MD
Neuroscience Visionary Award
from the AHA and the ASA in 2018
and is a graduate
of the Drexel University
Executive Leadership
in Academic Medicine program.
Dr. Lichtman has been the
principal investigator
for projects funded by
the Goddess Foundation,
the Fannie E. Rippel Foundation,
the American Heart Association,
the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention,
National Institute on Aging,
the Agency for Healthcare
Research and Quality,
the National Heart Lung
and Blood Institute
and the National Institute
of Neurological Disorders
and Stroke.
- All right, well, thank you.
So I have to say,
I mean, it's wonderful to,
to revisit some of those accomplishments,
but I wanna say I'm a graduate of the,
of the program here.
And so I have to say my
area was in epidemiology.
I have been living the past
little while across the bridge,
over in the school of public health
and around the medical center.
And what's really fun about coming today
and hearing that incredible project is
that I've always had roots in music
and dance
and art.
And I sort of feel like I'm enjoying
a treasure hunt across campus,
finding out about,
and really trying to build something that,
that goes beyond sort of my area,
but to really extend
across the different arts
and disciplines.
So what I wanna do today
is talk a little bit
about the vision of what
it is I'm trying to build.
And we're in process
share with you a course
and a new course
that's coming out this spring
that we're really excited about.
And then just tell you about one
or two projects.
And again,
I'm very interested in hearing
about potential collaborations
or opportunities,
cause it's really exciting
to see where you are in your,
your own career development.
And I have to say Yale
is an amazing space.
As I said,
I've been here a little while
and I'm still exploring new territory.
So it's a lot of fun.
So what we really wanna do
with the HAPPY Initiative is,
is develop an interdisciplinary program
that really builds on health,
the arts and humanities,
looking at all of the rich
resources across Yale.
We're basing it in the
school of public health.
That's my hub.
And we really are giving
it more of a public health perspective,
how to enhance the health of communities
through understanding
important public health issues,
but how can we translate it
and communicate it through the arts?
And so one of the things we have sort
of a three-pronged approach,
we wanna have collaboration,
which is what's exciting
here to sort of see
what everybody's doing to
really build collaborations,
to eventually establish a center
that focuses on this
with certainly invited scholars,
having guests artists,
and really having
a good hub for these
kinds of conversations.
We also wanna have education
to really train everybody to
use interdisciplinary arts
to promote community health.
And we are working on a
track within my school,
but also thinking across campus.
And then research
that's as you heard a bit of my hub is
to really conduct research
that evaluates
and comes up with how to measure outcomes
of art-based programming.
So how can we improve community health
and prove that a lot of this exposure
is really going to improve
an individual's health
and the overall health of their community.
So one of the things,
and I'm sure many of you are
from different areas here,
part of what is really fun.
And as I said,
the treasure hunt is to sort
of build collaborations.
And we've been doing
that very effectively.
So far we've been
working with individuals.
I should change it now
from School of Drama to the Geffen School.
So it's a little bit older, sorry,
but what is interesting is,
you know, again,
how many schools are under our umbrella,
but also we think about all
of the other art galleries,
museums, libraries,
everything else that are just
so rich to Yale to be thinking
about how can we incorporate programs
and conversations
that really bridge
across these disciplines?
One of the collaborations
that we're really excited
about is we've been
working with Garth Ross
and Jennifer Newman,
thinking about using
and working with the Schwarzman Center.
For me, as I said,
sort of being over in
the more medical campus,
it really is a wonderful environment.
I'm sure many of you
have already been there.
You've seen the beautiful new resources,
but it's amazing that the dance space,
all the different areas and technologies
that we're hoping to take advantage
of to really immerse
ourselves in thematic work
and also display so many
of the different arts
that are available.
And it really provides a
unique lens into public health
and the arts by being
able to have conversations
that bridge.
And I'll talk about one
or two of those.
Taiga Christie, who was a
graduate of our MPH program
and the social behavioral sciences is what
is an inaugural Schwartzman fellow.
What that means is it's
really exciting for us.
I mean, she knows the
disciplines of our work,
but she also is really having
important conversations
and introductions for us
within the Schwarzman Center,
to be able to think
about developing programs and events
that are dedicated to this intersection
and can also introduce
individuals across campus.
We feel that we're also helpful
to the Schwarzman Center's mission
of building a sense of belonging
by providing some of
these unique opportunities
to discover and connect.
And one of the themes
that we're working on right
now is a theme of sleep.
We all need sleep.
It's one of what we call sort of
the three pillars of a stool.
You know, you need to eat,
you need to exercise.
You also need to sleep.
And what's fun about this
is we've been starting
to have conversations
where we've been bringing
together the experts in sleep,
who can talk about
what you do when you
sleep brain cleansing,
circadian rhythms,
all the things that are really
important for your health.
We're also talking with,
for example,
individuals from the
Geffen School of Drama,
where we're talking about safety issues,
shift work,
how does that work?
We're also talking with individuals
about equity of sleep,
who has good sleeping environments.
We're working with professors
and individuals from the
school of architecture,
what is the ideal sleeping environment?
So we are starting to
think about not only the,
the broad range of importance of sleep
and how well it's connected.
We're thinking about plays and music,
all that have showcased
the importance of sleep
and the detrimental issues related
to not having adequate sleep.
And of course,
for all of us,
whether it be a graduate student level
or faculty level,
we know there,
there are important times
when we are not getting enough sleep.
And we have to think about
how that impacts health.
So stay tuned,
we're planning quite a few events
that we will be bringing
across campus to really think about
that and showcase it.
I'm also really excited when we think
about this kind of approach,
we have a incredible collaborator
that I was fortunate to be
introduced to about a year
and a half ago,
Dr. Neal baer,
he's a physician, author,
an award-winning show runner
and television writer/producer.
He is very passionate
about public health being an advocate,
and he really uses media
to tell impactful stories.
And so he works from the approach
that you need to have it
based in science and evidence,
but then you really have to
trigger an emotional response
to things it's not just about the numbers,
but how do you really invoke
the emotional response
to really wanna drive change
and end policy?
So again,
I would, his list is very long,
but again, I think for us,
it's really exciting to be working
with someone who is very visionary
and really wants to
connect all of the dots
and think about effective
storytelling because that,
for us as a public health discipline
and through many of the other
arts is really important
and compelling.
I also wanna mention Karen Derry,
who's here.
Who's really the hub of
making sure we connect
with everybody across campus.
So let me just,
so that's a collaboration education.
We really are trying to think
about multidisciplinary courses
that take advantage
of understanding public health issues
from the perspective of the science,
as well as how they might be displayed
to have been historically
and how they might be used
to really raise awareness
and invoke change.
So I wanna talk about my
Inaugural HAPPY Course
in just a minute,
but that's the,
as I said, collaboration, education,
and then research,
we really wanna build an
evidence base for ethical,
practical use of arts
and humanities to improve health outcomes.
It seems obvious,
but there really is an
important gap in the field.
And what's really exciting
from my perspective is
that organizations like
the National Institutes
of Health are really
recognizing this importance.
And there are now requests
for funding announcements.
For example,
I'm working with Dean Robert Blocker
from the School of Music.
There are new RFAs requests
for funding announcements
that are very much related
to brain health music,
all aspects of recovery as mentioned,
I'm very interested in stroke.
So stroke recovery is something
that's very interesting to
me to understand how music
and dance are very,
very helpful in recovery.
And then part of what's important.
And I've heard this from Garth,
from Schwartzman Center,
who's spent a lot of time down
at the Kennedy Center
for Arts is we also need
to be thinking about how
do you evaluate the impact.
And there really is a lot of
work methodologically to do.
So let me just take a couple of minutes
and talk about the course
that we're planning.
So this is a picture of
the historical library
over at the medical school,
which is gonna be very much
involved in our course.
We really wanna challenge our students
to explore the possibilities problems
and potential uses of arts
and humanities in public health.
So we're planning field
trips all around the campus.
We've already talked with
one of the art historians.
We're going to pull out a lot of materials
that have been historically provided,
whether it be how things
have been recorded,
how things have been
relayed in advertisements,
so that we really are
building conversations
around particular themes.
We wanna really look at
expertise across campus.
I'm gonna show you
pictures of other places.
We're gonna go on our field trip.
And we really wanna think
about methodologies,
not only study design
and things like that,
but how do we really think
about the impact of some of these things
on our own perceptions
and how will we utilize these to think
about community health?
Here we expect to be
going to the libraries.
I mean, the museums to really take a look
at how some public health
themes have been relayed in art.
And so the format,
which is very different
for me is we're gonna have sort
of two sessions a week.
One will be more lecture
oriented content area.
The other one's gonna be very hands-on,
it's gonna be going to,
as I said, some of the libraries,
some of the museums,
we have some concerts picked
out some performances,
so that we're really trying to reflect
on how these two are both integrated
and sometimes not integrated.
We're gonna really focus on ethics
and problems in art and health work,
storytelling, social cohesion,
and medical humanities,
and social science to kind of
build this methologic base.
And then we're really gonna be thinking
about what are some of the
important public health themes
that we wanna get across.
So some of them,
for example,
might be things like climate change,
disaster and humanitarian aid, opioids
and harm reduction,
violence and gun violence, sleep
and health disparities,
mental health, HIV aids,
the built environment
and health disparities,
health impact of incarceration,
which was wonderful to hear.
And we'll be working with
one of my former students,
Byron Kennedy.
I don't know if you've met him,
who's very involved in,
in the medical system for the
prison systems in Connecticut
and then neuroscience and the arts.
And I just wanna mention
that part of this also
is to look at plays.
This is actually a scene
from a play that was written,
directed and produced by,
as I mentioned,
Taiga Christie,
who is our fellow.
And it was an important piece in
that it really looked at the
stress of frontline workers,
EMS workers.
She did a qualitative work
to understand the issues
she developed a play,
and then it was shown to EMS workers
and their families.
And it led to very important discussions
about many of those issues.
The assessments that we're gonna do,
which is a little different
is weekly reading reflection.
So we really want people to think
about their response to
a lot of these issues so
that we really want people to come up
with where these things
connect in their own lives.
We want individuals to create a manifesto,
sort of a value assignment.
That's a kind of a living document
that will grow with the work
that they do.
And then we really want a final project,
which is to create an arts
or humanities inspired intervention
on a specific health topic.
I'm also showcasing here.
We talked about music.
This is one of our former students
who also had a wonderful
series of recitals
during her time here.
So that's the course,
a couple of things
that we have put together,
just to give you an idea,
is we hosted Dr. Neal Baer
had been the executive
producer for a documentary
Welcome To Chechnya,
which was a powerful
David France documentary
about anti-gay purges in the
late 2010s for LGBT refugees.
They were wearing hidden cameras,
made their way out of Russia
through a network of safe houses.
And it was really amazing.
It was a nominated,
it was on the shortlist,
I should say for an Oscar,
it won a Special Jury at Sundance.
What was interesting about it is
that we put together a panel,
which was Neal baer.
We also had our Dean John Pachankis,
whose really his area is an LBGTQ health.
Lyosha Gorshkov,
who's also in academics,
but has been a refugee
and also a lawyer Dierdre
Sradone who is an expert
in getting people asylum.
So it was really,
we provided the documentary.
We gave people time to look at it,
and then we really put together a panel
that we thought could get
at some of the issues,
the social political issues
that we thought would be really important.
We also, and it was
wonderful to see the readings
that in the letters
that you were describing.
(clearing throat)
We put together a pandemic archive,
and it's been very interesting.
We opened it up to the
El community and beyond,
and got wonderful contributions
about people's responses
and impressions and thoughts
about what their lives
were like during that time,
which we think as,
as you were hearing is a
really important expression
and a way for many people to
think about getting through
what was such a difficult time.
And then some other things we've done.
We provided opportunity for,
we invited a group of students
and staff across the whole
campus to view a play,
Do No Harm.
That was really around the stories
of three enslaved black women
and the medical experimentation
that they endured
and suffered through.
And following the screening,
we had a conversation with the playwright
and the play commissioner,
and really had a very wonderful dialogue
about many of the issues
that were involved.
And then finally, we have a
couple of things in process.
I mentioned Taiga Christie's
work Counting Pebbles,
but we also are currently working
and she's leading the
initiative on an original play
about climate change communication
in the context of COVID,
we got funding from outside
foundation for that,
and we're also gonna be
hosting a touring performance
of Ezelle in the spring.
So let me stop there
and just say, please if
they're interests contact me,
I would love to work very
much at the early stages
of developing something
and all ideas
and energy is welcome.
(audience applauding)
- [Man] So obviously there,
the research itself will have
an impact on the community,
other ways in which you're thinking
about involving the community
in some of this work?
- Oh, absolutely.
I think for us there,
by having some of the plays go out
in the community is certainly
one of those aspects,
but yes,
we're thinking about some
of the collaborations
and some of the projects
that we wanna do very much feel
that we wanna engage
individuals in the community so
that it feels like not
only is it nested here,
it's nested in New Haven,
we have been thinking also
about any kinds of work
that we could think about.
So one of the things we've been thinking
about is sort of a toolkit
where we go out into the
community on thematic issues
and really talk with individuals,
get their impressions.
What are some of the
challenges around this issue?
So we would definitely go
out to thought leaders,
individuals who are in
environment situations much,
like I think,
you know, yours was a perfect example.
And part of what we've been talking
about is trying to prepare a toolkit
that you put together,
some of the key messaging.
And we wanna be able to
then share that with,
with artists, with individuals, certainly,
but we are thinking about packaging.
We've been talking about working
with a singer songwriters in Nashville,
thinking about Neal's connected
with the Hollywood Guild,
making sure that some of these snippets
and experiences are
really going to outlets
where they would be shared as well
as providing potentially been
yet since stories about health
that could go out to the community
and be used for sparking
and igniting conversation
about health issues.
So yes,
we very much feel like
working in close collaboration
with individuals outside
of the Yale community
to really understand many aspects
and dimensions of public health
issues is really critical.
Thank you.
- [Man] Thank you so much
for that presentation.
I'm on the staff at 25 Yale,
which is the center for public services,
social justice on campus.
And in our experience,
we've worked with so
many community partners
with grassroots in arts initiatives
and other chains,
as well as performers
and artists individuals,
collectives, et cetera.
And one of the challenges
locally I suspect,
and I know nationally as well,
is that oftentimes arts organizations
and grassroots artists
struggle to obtain funding
for a lot of their art
and they all can feel
pressure to associate art
with something else.
So it's arts and resource development,
art and health
art and economic development,
for instance.
So how do you anticipate,
do you anticipate that your,
your findings in your research
will provide some tools
for organizations to be
able to seek more stable
and sustainable support
review and conversely,
how do you anticipate the
challenge of this exacerbating
that part of your challenge?
And then finally,
as part of that,
how do you consider kind
of the cultural equity of
a challenge of whose art
(mumbling)
- Sure, now those are great questions.
And I think those are very much issues
that we are processing.
I feel very fortunate that Taiga Christie,
who is an integral member
of our team raises our awareness very much
about these issues.
We are bringing artists into the class
and making sure
that all artists are
compensated appropriately so
that we also realize often in art,
it's almost as if it's supposed
to be a volunteer activity
or something,
which we are very cognizant it's,
as someone who's married to a violinist,
I very much appreciate
the sphere of the artists.
I think your question
about dissemination and sharing,
and also sustainability
are very much issues
that we're thinking about.
I think, as I mentioned in response,
the idea of the toolkit is to
make some of these insights
and thoughts and
impressions from individuals
and perspectives around
public health issues available
to artists.
So the idea is
that we would like to provide information
that could help them build their art.
Support their art.
I think ultimately for us as a center,
I very much wanna think
about opportunities
and resources to support
development of art
and sustainability of art.
I mean, I think we would like
to have artists and residents,
but also ultimately I would
very much like to have resources
that could go out to artists
for pilot programs exhibit.
So I think that for us a goal would be
to provide resources as well.
I think what is exciting
from my perspective
as someone who's been
in the research field,
I am seeing more and more recognition
of the importance of art in wellness.
There is an epidemiologist Daisy Fancourt
who's in the UK
who has really been
looking at large data sets
and demonstrating that exposure to art
and engagement can be associated
with preventive issues
for health longevity,
better mental health.
There are also positive
associations for children.
So I think,
you know, in the bigger picture,
I think it would be to
continue to find resources,
to support those things,
and then think about
interventions and programs
that would then enable artists
to be part of this sort
of community health.
Does that help answer the question?
Great, thank you, yeah.
- [Lady] Thank you so much.
(mumbling)
So I have a question polls from the local
if you could talk a little bit
about this initiative also
have some false impact
on Yale period as a employee employer,
because they hired a lot of artist
but also as you said
they are hiring all sorts
of people including graduate students,
people working in services,
advertising services.
(mumbling)
I'm wondering if some of the findings
that you are finding the discovering urge
is the arguing conversation also
with those in the 40 and on dumpers
to make the lines of
those who work here align
with the values and the
(mumbling)
- Okay, so if I'm understanding
that the question is,
is a bit of bringing
some of this work more
to the Yale administration
and staff,
is that, yeah,
so it's a great question.
I think we're still at
some early stages where we,
where we are working on
sort of the education,
the collaborations.
I mean,
I would anticipate that the programs
we put forward are to be to
the whole Yale community.
So for example,
the events that we're thinking about,
for example,
a health fair on sleep would
be open to everybody how
that might impact policy
as far as staff employees.
I think we're not,
I don't think we're there at this time,
but I appreciate the
perspective that it, again,
if these are effective opportunities,
interventions, exposures,
we would like to initially here, you know,
make them available to
the entire Yale community
as we discover things.
And as more comes out about the evidence,
I would hope that it would
certainly be something
that we would bring forward
to inform, you know,
overall community health
here within Yale as well.
Thank you.
- [Man] Great, thank you.
- Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)